we have a voicemail number it is
available 24 hours a day and many of you
do call at 2 3 4 5 in the morning here
is a call I got which actually brings up
a really interesting issue which is why
did it take this long to find out that
George Santos was lying about just about
everything and this is an important
question take a listen
hello David this is Aaron Cooper I had a
quick thought about George Santos as
well as lies
I'm wondering why his opponent Thomas
did not uncover all these Librarians
campaigns and I'm thinking the reason
why is because he ran for governor and
lost in the Democratic primary and I
think after he just lost motivation he
wasn't that interested in winning the
New York District just want to get your
thoughts thank you bye listen this is a
very good question
the George Santos lies
they could have been uncovered by his
opponent's opposition research they
could have been uncovered earlier we're
talking by investigative journalists but
they were not now I don't know enough
about the Dynamics to blame anyone in
particular but as a general principle
when you have a guy that it's not just
one lie it's not oh you know I used to
be a city councilor and I passed an
ordinance and then we research it and oh
you didn't pass that ordinance this was
lied about employment history lied about
educational history lied about ethnic
background religious background call it
what you want potentially lied about his
mom's death as a result of 9 11
definitely lied about having four
employees die in the Pulse Nightclub
shooting in 2016. I mean lie upon libon
claimed he claimed he owned property and
sold a property but now says oh I never
claim to own property I can't give you
all the lies that he told
it is a failure
and maybe it remains to be seen who
failed that neither investigative
journalism nor opposition research
turned up the fact that this guy was
making it all up and uh maybe it will be
an instructive example for the future
but I think that that's a very good
point on today's bonus show we are going
to start with what is genuinely a sad
story friend of the show Jamie Raskin
Democratic congressman who I think would
be a great candidate for president
has announced that he has cancer and he
says it is serious but treatable and
that he expects to make a full recovery
we're going to talk about it we will
also talk about an incident in which a
terminally ill patient in a hospital was
vaping cannabis and police were called
and it escalated very quickly and in
France they have passed the law Banning
single-use tableware meaning disposable
forks and knives at fast food
restaurants what is the size of that
carbon footprint how much of a different
will it make is it practical do people
like it are they Furious very
interesting decision in France all of
those stories and more wait we're David
sir where are these stories they're on
the bonus show today oh the bonus show
where you and make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves
is bad that's right memberships which
include access to the bonus show fund
staff salaries benefits Health Care
connectivity equipment legal we need a
lot of legal folks
Etc you can sign up at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show you'll get the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show and
you will be invited to our members only
Town Halls all of that and more sign up
at joinpakman.com I'll see you then and
then we will be back tomorrow with the
final episode of 2026. sorry of 2022.
we'll see you then